few people in history witness a war when
a Pulitzer Prize and worked for the
President of the United States former
ambassador to the United Nations
Samantha power served under President
Obama following him from the Senate to
the Oval Office she shares her story in
a new memoir the education of an
idealist power writes about growing up
as an Irish immigrant in the u.s.
covering Bosnia as a war reporter and
campaigning for human rights she joins
us for her first TV interview about the
book commanded Samantha good morning
welcome thanks for being here great to
be here you you write that the sources
of America's strength our diversity
individual rights and leadership but you
see them as being under threat ow well
we have a president who's walked away
from our alliances cozied up to regimes
that don't respect human rights for
reasons that make very little sense
and unfortunately attacked institutions
that make us very strong at home and not
taking pride in our diversity indeed
kind of shunned it so it's going to be
very hard to recover from this period in
American history but there is a hunger
out in the world and there is a need on
behalf of the American people to do so
former Vice President Joe Biden is
running to change course in America you
work with him closely for years he sware
you in as UN ambassador fair to say you
endorsed his presidency I'm not here to
endorse I just spent the last few years
working on a book where I tried to dig
into what public service is really like
and Joe Biden is certainly the
embodiment of public service having
dedicated his whole life to serving the
American people but I think right now
we're so polarized that coming together
over a story of one individual trying to
go into public service and the bumps and
the bruises and the juggle as a mother
and as somebody trying to promote human
rights in an unfriendly world that's
what I tried to do rather than get into
the thick of the political fray right
now I feel we need to come together and
a story sometimes is one way to do that
even before President Obama took office
you were warning him about Afghanistan
when you look at where we are right now
with Afghanistan and the impact that a
possible deal with the Taliban could
have on women what's your concern there
well all
have to be concerned about what
terrorist groups and radical extremists
want to do with women what the Taliban
did do to women we have the track record
of that I think the challenge for the
American people in the US government and
our leadership in the world is that
we've been there for 18 years and our
soldiers have served five six tours in
some cases and they've borne the brunt
of this conflict and we need to pursue a
negotiated solution and try to use the
leverage we have in the Taliban's desire
for us not to be there to ensure some
basic protections we've also trained
thousands of Afghan security forces over
the years and you know the hope is that
they'll be able to hold their ground and
that the Taliban won't revert to what
they were doing before the United States
got involved in the first place are you
concerned about the impact on Afghan
women if still struck we have it I'm
concerned about that but equally us
being there is not defeating the Taliban
fundamentally we're at a stalemate and
again after 18 years I think it's time
to bring our soldiers home some of the
most gut-wrenching passages in the book
are about your efforts to become a mom
and then also the juggle of having work
demanding work and and dealing with home
life could you talk a bit about what you
learned and we put that on the page well
one of the themes of the book is not so
much lean in which of course I also
believe in but lean on how impossible it
is to balance a full-time national
security job but but also how hard it is
for so many parents to balance the work
that they do and to feel like they're
doing enough for their kids or for their
their partner their spouse for that
matter
so one of the scenes in the book I
described is you know being on a call
and my son trying to get my attention to
give him the score of a baseball game
Washington Nationals game and for every
parent has that experience of just
trying to shoo their kid away and I
happened to be on the phone with the
Secretary General of the United Nations
no but it's the same and but in my case
as he stomps off with resentment he
stomps off saying putin putin putin
putin
and is it going to be Declan Declan
Declan Declan and well you never forget
that do indeed but but to try to open it
up and to show
women and men who are doing this juggle
none of us feel adequate in doing it to
show the vulnerability and yet to
soldier on and to try to try to be
resilient you also write about having
struggles with fertility in the middle
of all this I do in fact and and that I
decided to include that because I
remember sort of the moment I was
working at the White House and I was
keeping my little private journey and
Odyssey or my husband of my journey very
private and thinking you know you think
you're alone and that you're the only
one going through this and I happen to
mention it to some person a woman
colleague and turns out she was going
through the exact same thing and then
the more open I was about it the more I
realized there's a community of women
who are who are going through this and
we should just know that there's no
stigma to it it's just sometimes what
you have to do in order to have the
family that you see and with all of your
experiences I love at the end of this
book you say if one lesson in my
experience stands out above the others
it is that the people we love are the
foundation for all else and it sounds
like when you talk about the accident
your husband was then shortly after all
of this comes down to the support from
your family absolutely I mean I I went
through this transition of having got to
serve President Obama and be in the
cabinet the president United States
January 20th turned in my badge get kind
of shoot out the door as President Trump
took over and I was very focused on our
politics and everything that's happened
as I should be but when your husband
gets in an accident it puts everything
in perspective and and to get the
balance right and try to emphasize your
kids and your spouse and sort of sowing
your own garden is every bit of court
it's the foundation also for having the
right kind of politics the book is done
so at least you can go publicize it and
then back to home yes balance will be
restored yeah basilar power thank you
very much we appreciate it the education
of an idealist is on sale Tuesday